la 11e édition des jeux des collégiens
de l'ouest s'est déroulé sur la plage
des brisants à saint-gilles en présence
de plus de 500 jeunes en tournoi de
beach soccer et de pigeon volé a été
organisée sous la tutelle qu'elle unss
ce sont des matches je dirais très
festif le but c'est bien entendu de
jouer mais aussi de s'amuser et de
prendre plaisir à une activité je dirais
qu'ils n'ont pas l'habitude de faire
parce que bon au port on est toujours
sur du synthétique ou parfois du gazon
mais j'ai fait chaud il ya le soleil et
s'amusant parce qu'on a nos camarades
est tout aussi tu es mais pour moi c'est
la première fois que je fais me soccer
et c'est bien voilà cette journée était
placée sous deux thèmes le sport mais
également le respect de l'environnement
le tc eaux étaient donc présents est
proposé aux collégiens de visiter leurs
stands afin de les sensibiliser au tri
sélectif des déchets sur un événement
comme ceux ci on sensibilise les jeunes
concernant l'environnement
on les apprend à jeter ajouter les bons
déchets dans la bonne poubelle donc à
mieux trier comme ça pour éviter par
exemple du fait de recycler le pardon on
va économiser du bois donc on explique
ça aux jeunes on les explique aussi on a
aussi des activités manuelles telles que
par exemple comme ma collègue viennent
le faire pour pas mal de jeunes
la fabrication d'un porte-monnaie avec
une brique de lait comme ça ça évite de
jeter et les jeunes sont sont intéressés
un rendez vous annuel devenu
incontournable organisé par l'union
nationale du sport scolaire une
organisation réussie selon dominique
laterrière chargé de mission à l'urss et
michel kayser directeur de l'urss l'urss
de la réunion c'est une formidable
machine
c'est une machine qui est à l'image de
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui sur ces jeux
organisés par l'ouest
c'est une machine qui
y accueille vingt mille jeunes de toute
l'île c'est une machine qui crée de
l'émotion tout au long de l'année 25
activités sportives et puis aussi c'est
une machine c'est une organisation qui
crée beaucoup de réussite
de la part des élèves je ne sais tu pas
que du sport c'est aussi plus que du
sport puisque associés à toutes nos
manifestations
on a toujours le souci du développement
durable de la féminisation des pratiques
et de faire de nos jeunes réunionnais
les futurs adultes de demain
voilà une organisation qui tourne très
bien parce qu'il ya un petit savent de
collègues qui est là depuis 7h du matin
et on prépare tout donc sur le plan de
l'organisation aucun problème sur le
plan de la manifestation sur la journée
par la suite ça se passe très bien si
parce qu'on a des élèves qui sont
nickels n'est ce pas les filles à une
onzième édition triomphante
un véritable moment de convivialité et
de partage sous un temps somptueux